at the UCI I make new eco light that it
can make advanced biofuels like not just
ethanol they can make a very long chain
alcohols that can have much higher
energy density or I make some non
natural amino acids they can be a
building blocks of some blockbuster
drugs so there's a big challenge in the
biodegradable industry how to make
something that is elastic and prezbo
so you can make it so you can use them
for different applications that's how I
came up with this kind of solution to
make a new module that is biodegradable
that is bio derive that is available for
commercial production and in this modern
age the most important thing is how can
you combine all different knowledge to
come up with new solutions new devices
new thought that a computer cannot do
that anyone else cannot do
it's called personality you should be
your own and your own may be able to
change the world nothing else from my
own experience we need to love the
planet planet just like we love our
family know someone's opinion may
contradict yours where is my friend
Allen it's all about your perspective
who are we and what is the nature of
this reality what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Alan Sakia
we are on site at the beautiful West
Lake University in Hangzhou China we are
now going to be talking about
sustainable industrialization and
circular economics we have dr. Ketchum
zhang joining us on the show hi kitchen
thanks Alan thank you so much for coming
on our show I really appreciate it
I'm so excited for this conversation for
those who don't know captions background
he's professor and p.i at the School of
Engineering at West Lake University
focused on designing greener chemical
production processes and new
environmentally friendly materials for a
more sustainable path to
industrialization and circular economics
he is the inventor of scalable
sugar-based biodegradable rubber and you
can find the links in the bio below
ketcham let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions we like asking
our guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world so we have 8
billion people right now we are going to
have 9 10 11 billion people very soon
maybe in just one decade or two decades
how can we find enough food chemicals
materials to supply to so many people in
the same time keep our environment
intact there's a big challenge in in
everywhere of the world yeah how can we
sustainably meet the basic requirements
of living for a growing population of
people that want to live more and more
in a developed industrialized way and we
need green technology sustainable
solutions for these processes and I like
how you put this you put this as
industrializing but doing it in a more
sustainable way I like that I like that
focus of yours okay let's talk about
we'll get more into this as we continue
the show let's talk about your journey
and how you even got to become who you
are today how did you get interested in
science when you were young
actually my father was a geologist so he
kept me on them of my name's Katoon in
Chinese it means the spin of science the
spirit the spring the spring of science
yes and now I was born I was born on the
Earth Day April at any second so so it's
like a good you need fur on this
beginning and then my when I was a kid
we move around China so I appreciate the
beauty of nature so I would like to keep
the nature as beautiful as it is all the
time but in the past four decades you
can see China has experienced a big
change the economy is growing in the
same time the environment the
environment has big issues so we make
more and more chemicals we make more and
more cars so we can see our pollution
people need to wear masks in Beijing or
Shanghai all those big cities and our
cars on the street emit so much smoke
every day so this some people like this
kind of modern lifestyle but for many
people it could be a big torture
actually a health hazard yes in the
hazard for nature as well work choking
the area that we live in for the clean
air we're choking it with our landfills
with our garbage not circular
genomics yes yeah so both father was Jia
logistic my my my father was geologist
Telesis yeah and then you were born on
Earth Day yes - cool and then they was
in Bay High uh niave high near Bay High
yeah near Bay High which is I'm the very
south coast of of China
yes and it's kind of like you were
saying like a very like Hawaii of the is
how I yeah he said know why I like that
and then you were also teaching me did
you end up living and googling oh did
you live there at all I was I was always
moving from one place to learn we're
always moving
yes interesting when you were young
moving even yeah so I never stay in one
place more than nine years did you live
in goo goo lien at all or just very
short time so every time you know yeah
and this is known as one of the most
beautiful destinations of the eastern
hemisphere along with hyung job but
where where right now but and for those
that don't know it's GU i L i N and look
it up it's just gorgeous
Bill Clinton visited in there so yeah
yeah it's it's it's unbelievable I mean
I I gotta go ah but it looks so amazing
I love we really appreciate you teach me
about that and even Bay High - this is a
really important places to go - people
just think of the major cities when they
think of China and so I think it's
really important to share these gems in
these other locations in China also
either
that's why nature is so important to me
I have seen all these beautiful places I
appreciate the beauty of nature so yeah
when you see the beauty of guellen--
or of Yosemite like in California you
become more aware of the importance of
preserve
these beautiful natural sights of the
planet and not just saying yeah let the
industry come in and cut down all the
trees and and put hotels up everywhere
and yeah it's a it's very important but
early in the same time we are human
being we love to drive
we love to fly so we cannot abandon our
modern lifestyle yes this is a very
important point too so okay so we figure
out how to advance our modern lifestyle
in a sustainable path of
industrialization and then that makes it
so that all of our travel is cleaner all
of our food is cleaner all of an
agriculture is cleaner all of our
chemicals are cleaner we're gonna talk
about this so you ended up going to the
University of Science and Technology in
China for polymer science and
engineering and how did you end up like
picking that as what you were interested
in that's very specific polymer science
polymer being long chains of carbon yes
because I love chemistry but in the same
time I want to use chemistry to make
some things
so polymer end up to be a good hackett
so if we watch a movie one of the most
fun one of the most famous movies that
graduate so the you watch to the end
where should you go plastics yeah yeah
yeah it's interesting so you were
teaching me that polymers are the third
largest manufacturing industry in the
United States yes yeah that's that's
huge
okay and in the top ten polymers that we
use are non biodegradable in the world
the top ten in the world are non
biodegradable and chemically synthesized
and chemically soon
sighs okay and and we'll get to
explaining this a little bit more too
but the the names of them are
polyethylene and polypropylene and PT of
like full of coca-cola bottles is B TT
yeah interesting
for like coca-cola bottles all of the
packaging around those little thin film
plastic packaging around our goods
oh the iPhone top iPhone top interesting
yeah yeah yeah
so yeah polymers are a massive industry
and figuring out how to prioritize
making them biodegradable is very
important but not abandoning the modern
lifestyle like you were indicating to
but sustaining our beautiful nature so
okay so then from there it was doing
your PhD at actually California
Institute of Technology
so studying biomaterials and doing the
PhD in chemistry so this toe teaches
about this move how did you decide to
make the move to the United States for
the PhD and what was it first like when
you've gotten into the culture US has
has been the center of science for for a
long long time and I believe it will
continue so so I think pursuing a PhD in
US can provide me more opportunities
just banty and none of these I think
experience more different cultures I
think diversity is important either for
education for science of our own
personality that's why I made a move and
Caltech has been a great place for
science and in Union and it's near
Hollywood you can find anything in the
center's why not
yeah I like your focus on visiting other
parts of the world that have a strong
scientific advancement happening that's
why we're here in China as one of the
reasons like we want to come to a place
in the world that has a very serious
scientific advancement happening and we
want to interview the leaders in those
fields and then share that with the
world and the USA is a very mixing pot
of culture so you got to immerse
yourself in a very deep diversity of
cultures when you were in the u.s. in LA
and when I come to China I get to
immerse myself in the diversity of China
a Chinese culture even though it's more
homogenized only Chinese mostly here but
still I get a completely different
cultural vibe being here and I think
that's really important for trying to
bring the world closer together so
you're doing your PhD in Caltech me
coming here for interviews and stuff
these types of moves are very important
for especially young people to do
they're into chips yeah yeah to
introduce you meet the cultures of
people make friends in the different
parts of the world then all of the media
stuff it seems like it doesn't matter
because I have friends I know that we
have love and friendship and
collaboration across the countries and
the media is just selling me fear and
other nonsense
so if so if you look at the most from my
own perspective if you look at them most
two important inventions in China I
believe is the paper and printing
because it allowed they allow the spread
of knowledge everywhere most people when
they think about the invention of paper
and the printing press to spread ideas
and knowledge around the world I think
they think of the
printing press and Johannes Gutenberg in
early 1400s and and then also even prior
to that we using papyrus and other like
animal skins to be able to write on and
then you know not so easily being able
to like erase and having no migrate over
things and all this type of stuff when
was the paper and the in the the people
in printing and printing was original
develop in China when we maybe two to
three thousand years ago I can eat that
you'll remember that day's interesting
and even prior to that we had all of the
the art cave paintings believe those
were like tens of thousands of of years
ago so and this leads us up to all the
way up to you were saying that the
internet for the spread of ideas yes and
then for some event Celtic actually
Celtic people like Bill Shockley and
Gordon Moore they caught their PhD or
bachelor's degree in at the Caltech and
then they invented a semiconductor
industry and then it led to the internet
and then we can talk and then other
parts of robot condition so that's
amazing from paper to internet now it's
change of ideas can be instant it does
not take days or years so I think
because of this kind of technology
development we can move our society our
society first of all force
fast forward but how can we keep our
basic needs that's another issue yes
yes I love that way of viewing the
cultural dissemination of knowledge
increasing over time we also have to
take into consideration things like the
signal-to-noise ratio so how much you
know now that we have the internet
everyone can publish things to everybody
how much of it is signal and how much of
it is noise and so it's a very also very
interesting question to ask and when the
printing press first came out how many
of the things that were being printed
were signal versus noise so these are
interesting questions what about the PhD
that you did at Caltech what was that in
what were you studying in your thesis
oh I studied by materials and how to
design different materials from scratch
so it taught me some principles on
materials chemistry and um how to
incorporate the latest knowledge in
chemistry biology engine union it's a
small place just like Westlake
University but physics chemistry nears
are very close so it allows exchange of
ideas very easily so you can come up
with new ideas in a better way maybe
yeah and then you did the non postdoc
afterward in bio manufacturing at the
department of chemical and biomolecular
engineering at UCLA so what were you
doing in that three year period so I
designed new bio synthetic pathways to
like advanced biofuels or new
pharmaceuticals so it's like a beer
brewing process we fit our engineer box
sugar and then they make whatever you
want not whatever something we can do
here you can feel
sugar as an input yes and you can
synthetically engineer the box like the
e.coli or is you could make a coli or
yeast out the other side or sugar in I
change the DNA in e.coli or East so they
like is in your beer brewing process
year they become the new chemical plant
so they process the sugar sugar goes to
the chemicals we want oh
okay so there's yeast or ecoli inside
that take sugar as the input and then
they turn the output into what do what
you want
what yes fields or chemicals and
materials and which chemicals and
materials are interested in than
producing at is you see I make new eco
light that can make other ones biofuels
like not just earth no they can make a
very long chain alcohols that can have
much higher energy density or I make
some non natural amino acids they can be
the building blocks of some blockbuster
drugs Wow you can make a coli turn sugar
into non natural amino acids yes cool
that you can't find anywhere else in
biology not very common not very because
you cannot assay you can never find
anything the life is different you can
so maybe you're gonna find this on mouth
okay okay so now natural amino acids and
also the other one was advanced biofuels
danced biofuels okay so
you said long chain alcohols alcohols
okay and so if you can convert a sugar
into biofuels and sugar into non natural
amino acids did you immediately find
applications for those did people want
to turn the sugar into biofuels right
away yeah my pasta otherwise I was the
leading figure in the biofuel research
he called some enterprise for no
president actually whoa a prize from the
the President Obama yeah from President
Obama yeah Wow
for the labs for the lab some research
whatever just still is are incredible
and then did has the technology of you
know turning sugar into a biofuels or
non natural amino acids did has that
been implemented into commercial
applications yeah there's a company
added yourself working on that area
right now so awesome okay so it's been a
long time for you with working with
sugar we'll talk about this so you went
after the postdoc and took assistant
professorship at the Department of
Chemical Engineering material science at
the University of Minnesota and
ironically enough we were both from 2010
to 2012 there we might have walked past
each other it's very interesting and you
continued working as you were in the
professorship you continued working with
sugar to make different things you ended
up inventing scalable sugar based
biodegradable rubber and that's
important because it can be used as an
alternative to petroleum so teach us
about how you ended up inventing this
sugar based biodegradable rubber and why
it's important actually
Minnesota has one of the best research
centers in polymer science so also the
chemical engineering is almost the best
in the country that's why I chose
Minnesota to start my career layer and
then there I met professor Frank pace
and professor McHugh my loboc on how to
make PLA another
biodegrade a polymer like that has
different properties actually PLA was
made is made in is made by nature walks
a local company in Minnesota they can
make PLA the problem is P is very rich
it is like glass it can easily fall
apart if you just saw it
so like several years ago when Sun chip
made the potato back from PLA they made
too much noise just because the property
is not good enough then they told me
this is a big problem how can you make
puree that's flexible enough so it does
not make too much noise and you can lead
to not easily fall apart that could be
apply to many more different scenarios
in our life so there's a big challenge
in the biodegradable industry how to
make something that is elastic and
fastball so you can make so you can use
them for different applications
that's how I came up with this kind of
solution to make a new material that is
biodegradable that is biota right that
is available for commercial production
in elastic and flexible yeah as well
okay I see you were given this challenge
and then you figured out how to create
this from biomaterials and so what is
this sugar based biodegradable rubber
how do you input sugar in is it similar
with the e.coli or yeast again yes we
put some DNA we change the DNA of e.coli
lay you in put sugar and then the end
near equal I will output a new polymer
monomer and then we polymerize the
monomer and is super elastic for example
that can be stretched to 18 times of
office or it'll land without breaking
Wow
it's biodegradable but is flexible like
rubber up to 18 times flexible like
rubber and biodegradable yeah Wow
you can get a yeast you can genetically
engineer a yeast to take sugar in and
produce a polymer monomer out the other
side yes see this is also so interesting
it makes me wonder how we can leverage
ancient like e.coli and yeast ancient
biology to engineer these things that
are billions of years old that could
potentially
two new tops do new jobs more
sustainably and where industrial is a
sustainably and environmentally friendly
you blue beer you do make fruition yeah
you to know the put an explosive bomb
somewhere in the city
interesting so maybe the question could
be something like could we have big bio
reactors filled with genetically
engineered yeast that is taking lots and
lots of sugar in and producing some
sustainable biomaterials out the other
side and is that process efficient
because we have to make sugar if to grow
sugar yes and if we're doing that
process unsustainably then that's not
too good but if we're growing it very
sustainably this is through sugarcane
usually yes it's our sourcing sugar like
in Brazil sugar cane sugar to ethanol is
sustainable business yes sugar death no
yeah for gas for powering yeah in Brazil
the ties run by ethanol yeah completely
yeah Oh or blend blend with oh they do
have some cars that are run by pure
ethanol yeah that but pure - yeah yeah
okay so you're always doing a
calculation then on how was the sugar
and how was the yeast sourced and
produced so that this input side of the
production process takes less energy
than what you get on the output is a
greater amount of
energy is a greater amount of value than
what you put on the input side so that's
this great also big question that needs
to be asked of all these chemical
engineers and biomaterials producers is
make sure that that process so very
similar to things like nuclear fusion is
we want to make sure that when we fuse
atoms that were spending much less
energy than that we get out yeah just
yeah that's why my experience I mean the
soda helps a lot because I taught the
introduction to chemical engineering so
lesson number one in chemical engineers
you have even you have out your out must
be bigger than you in otherwise forget
about it yeah straight up forget about
it if it's not bigger though it has to
be bigger bigger in terms of the energy
economy energy environment yeah a lot of
things to consider
yeah yeah okay okay so then where can
this specific invention scalable
sugar-based biodegradable rubber where
can these stretchable elastic polymer
monomers be used in the real world
applications so for example we can make
these kind of homes this yeah and
actually we have a new technology right
now so we microphones and then we can
crack them and we hit them then we can
recycle our monomer pack so it's the
first kind of the recyclable polymer
besides biodegradable that's one
possibility all we can make a plastic
bags that do not make a noise they are
just like the picture based polyethylene
bags look the same property but it our
materials biodegradable or we can make
agriculture film for
famine now the agriculture film is based
on polyethylene it damages our land the
footed the fertility jobs a lot because
of those are PE particles so if we in
the future we scale up our production
and the farmers use of a biodegradable
film then the land can be rescued in the
long run okay so already many different
applications and ok this move to west
lake to july 2019 to the school of
engineering get west lake you decided to
take on professorship and the principal
investigation starting the lab here so
the lab focus on a more sustainable
industrialization path new
environmentally friendly materials
circular economics greener chemical
production processes what do you want to
how do you want to achieve that goal how
why is that go important and how can we
achieve it i can give you an example so
I grew up in ecology province so 20
million people in my province work on
sugarcane industry 20 million people but
they only produce along 10 billion US
dollars of value per year and is highly
protein but there's a company called a
buil in Chicago and not at a company
pretty well it only has 30,000 people
30,000 employees the end new revenue is
30 billion US dollars so in China you
can see these kind of scenarios
everywhere
many people walk on low value industry
in the same time in the industry
generates a lot of protein stuffs so
they I realize maybe I can use my
knowledge and creative ideas to help
these people maybe the value can be
increased a little bit more importantly
I can affect more people maybe 20
million people instead of 20 or 30
thousand people there's a much bigger
gym and much bigger need does one idea I
have another idea happens in China we
were always told by our parents or our
professors you need to do listen to that
but when I moved to the United States
one big lesson I learned is be your own
only you can make Newtons because when
you create some thing is based on your
knowledge your personality everyone is
different but we never had this kind of
change in China before so westlake can
be a new model for this kind of you do
your own be original yeah yeah Wow okay
so I really like this paradigm of
thinking that you know take on this big
great Grand Challenges and you can be
the one that tackles a really important
industry change that needs to happen and
build the new frontier and only you can
do that so go and do it partner with
other people get their help go and do it
be an entrepreneur be a scientist push a
frontier be an artist and being educated
in educators so then your students can
spread your sauce all they can be you're
like a middle nuclear
yeah so you push the edge and then you
also teach how you've been pushing the
edge and teach what you know so other
people can go and push it even more
creatively with you and then after you
to get this teaching aspects crucial
okay let's go to the example you
mentioned first in the guanxi province a
third of the people so out of 60 million
people 20 million of them work on
sugarcane and the output of that
industry is about 10 billion US dollars
a year per year for 20 million people
whereas you gave this example of a
company in the United States that has
30,000 people you could also probably
use the same example with Alibaba or 10
cent or any of the other software
companies in China as so many more
people come to Amazon or or Apple yeah
yeah yeah so the idea is that we're
talking like a hundred billion or more
per year profit for these companies that
is made by an almost two orders of
magnitude less people so a hundred times
less people make ten times more money
yes which is very crazy to think about
stuff like that and that usually
if you have something happening like
sugarcane you were actually teaching you
there is actually a waste product that
comes from the sugarcane process and the
waste of water comes from that process
and that you and your lap can do things
like convert that to protein for animal
feed yes
so in the past so the fact that is just
dump the water in the river system it it
has been a big pollution problem for a
long long time it has never been solved
easily but if we can convert this kind
of waste water into some valuable
products such as protein that could
increase the value of the whole process
in the same time because farmers see
value from wastewater they are not going
to dump them into the river yes they see
value and then they will convert that
wastewater into animal protein feed okay
and how did you guys do the process of
converting it into animal feed protein
so there is carbon in the waste water
like some digested sugar or some fiber
so we can do some engineering of the box
then the bus can take in the cabin and
then they can do some metabolic
assimilation then the cabin will go to
proteins instead of some LT blew me in
the liver yeah and then which protein
would you want them to make the box so
something like a soybean protein because
the second biggest commodity product
that the China impasto in the United
States is essentially it's the protein
size the protein sauce in China is
sweeping yes I mean for animal fighting
fit yeah so like all of the ducks
outside of Beijing they teamed up for
the big how yeah tip its young
yeah and she they're eating soybeans
that are being imported from the US yeah
and so you can potentially grow the
soybeans from Willie slaughter
well you can some thought that's cool
yeah yes yes you know what's a good
question to ask that eight billion
people on the planet if you take you
know something like the wastewater and
if you don't have an idea that there's
value there like you're saying that do
you think that if you dump the waste
water into the river do you think this
has a downstream effect or no so good
question ask people because if people
stink no there's no effect that can dump
whatever I want
then they lack the understanding of the
interconnectedness of all nature so then
that would be a good teaching lesson for
someone that thinks that if I dump the
waste water there's no effect there's a
big effect that the river can turn black
and it can become very smelly
it will visit some big cities in Asia
you know that yeah we've had some
similar issues in the United States as
well and basically developing
industrializing countries sometimes
didn't proceed with very sustainable
methods okay and how would so this is
also another interesting question
because a lot of people think about like
if you were to tell me that Oh Alan why
don't you just keep your your orange
peel right I have some oranges over
there why don't you just keep your
orange peel on the table and and I'll
have someone come and pick the up the
compost so the convenience thing right I
can take the waste water and how long do
I have to wait until you
get up and converted into the animal
feed how much money will you give me for
the wastewater is it worth my time yes
these are very important questions yeah
it's always for any scientific ingenuity
you need to know some economics yeah
yeah so what would be the ideal
economics do you think for something
like convincing the farmer that's doing
sugarcane production to take the
wastewater and and you give them
incentive what would be the good enough
incentive the best would be if your
technology is cleaned up just you
sneaked in your car you're developed
technology it can be economically viable
ready is were always harder to use to
force someone to do something
what would we if we were smart maybe we
would put the sugarcane development next
to the duck or the pig fine then in the
middle is your wastewater to animal feed
protein conversion system so the
sugarcane in the duck or pig farm are
kind of next to each other with the
middle being the conversion process that
would it be a puppy - scenario yeah if
the land can work for both sugarcane and
for pig and also if if it's down the
line we may figure out methods like
clean meat where we can grow meat in bio
reactors from the pig stem cell or the
duck Sam saw yesterday artificial meat
is a hot topic in us right now regular
Beyond The Meat Company order
impossible bugger you can buy a grocery
stores and restaurants now which is so
exciting if you haven't yet go and try
it it's so good so that's why we hope
more and more things can come from
biotechnology yes from chemicals from
materials or maybe even meat yes so it
is environmentally friendly and consumes
less energy resource how good can it be
right yeah especially when you put the
blindfold on and I give you both duck
from the duck as well as duck grown in
the bioreactor and you taste it and then
you can't tell the difference when it
gets to that level plus the bioreactor
is much cheaper too and you don't have
to kill the conscious animal yes big did
big thumbs up huge planetary difference
yeah okay let's go through the other
examples so that was the really good
example we gave on on we talked about
polymers at the beginning of that being
the direct manufacturing industry and
solutions for that
we talked about changing wastewater
converting that into protein for animal
feed that being one of them let's talk
about the alternative to cyanide so
cyanides used in the manufacturing
process how can you make an alternative
to cyanide a sign that has big has been
a big issue in China as well if you
heard of Tianjin explosion it happened
several years ago in China so several
hundred times of cyanide just went
within the environment that could be
detrimental to a lot of stars but in the
same time a lot of animal feeds vitamins
amino acids manufacture from
night so we can we are coming up with
new ideas that I can use biotechnology
use and need but that can replace the
cyanide process then in the future we
won't be afraid of chemical plant near
the city you never know what's going to
happen in this kind of chemical plans
they may explode and then too they can
be very very dangerous just like a
Tianjin scenario what are we using
cyanide for right now to introduce like
some amino group or to activate some
carbonyl groups for certain chemicals
okay
or to recover code actually do recover
gold yeah interesting and then what
would you do to produce the alternative
to cyanide is this again sugar in and
then she'll get you talk it out and you
know cyanide in between yeah yeah yeah
interesting and you have to figure out
how to genetically engineer either yeast
or eco like to take sugar and make an
alternative to cyanide yes okay that's
one of the things that labs focused on -
yes
okay okay let's talk about also the
alternative to round up so right now
we're spraying roundup on weeds
we have we spray lots of herbicides
pesticides on our growing food and we
don't know how it affects us down the
stream when we eat the food and also how
the the crops build resilience over time
so what do you think is a similar
process again where you take in sugar
into genetically engineered Easter
e.coli and they produce an alternative
to Roundup
oh that's one possibility okay so there
are two possible directions maybe we can
make some natural herbicides layer from
some weird organisms but if we can
somehow manipulate ourselves the anti
new cells they can make this neutral or
herbicides much more efficiently and
they they derive from nature that can be
biodegradable then you can solve the
roundup issue that's one direction and
nano direction is culinary media are
good replacements of long top cryo-cell
already but they are very expensive so
if I can combine biotechnology and green
chemistry to make this kind of roundup
replacements more environmentally
friendly and as cheap as crosses then
the farmers can rotate to use different
herbicides
then the chalk resistance won't be a big
issue I think this is a global
challenging carama challenge it happens
in China
it happens in India it happens in the
United States we we need to find a
solution to this big problem
and I believe we will be able to do it
yes how does you and your lab figure out
how to genetically engineer the yeast or
the e.coli to be able to find these
alternatives to cyanide alternative to
Roundup what do you do to say okay if we
engineer it this way maybe we'll produce
this alternative that's a good question
and tough question many people ask me
this question at this moment I can only
tell them it's not easy you I have so
many I had so many sleepless nights just
to think about stuffs and because I got
a change in chemistry I collagen in
biology like all these possible organic
reactions all these possible metabolic
reactions in a Cell in my brain
even so I need to try to combine this
and that so that's not easy right now
but I believe since artificial
intelligence pick up data moving on fast
so maybe in the future I can but with
the computer scientists to design some
new process just in a computer first
then we can like an now computers better
than at playing chess and go and goes
but in the future they can they can
design some new stuffs for us as well I
love the bio simulation space yes so
instead of it all having to be in your
head and you only be you know you have
to sleep eight hours a day you have to
you have less processing ability of all
of the permutations the combinations and
so you can leverage the artificial
intelligence big data and you can
potentially run a bunch of different
genetically engineered East and e-coli
and simulate out if they produce good
alternatives to cyanide and roundup yes
so in at least eight I can we can only
pick some possible targets but in the
future this can be this can be much much
bigger yeah and then our world can be
much much better yes okay so let's do
other examples as well so we have
something that's also pretty popular is
and we see this quite often I mean in
the United States when you were there
talking about this before we started
that so many people have their own
personal clothes dryer in their homes
and when I was visiting Armenia two
years ago in Yerevan actually reminds me
a little bit of China in some ways very
you know older places in the world and
it's true that in China - just like in
Yerevan that in the summer you hang the
clothes outside to get dried by the
natural Sun instead of using the dryer
and you told me you said well Alan if we
could design a clothes dryer that would
use even one third of the less energy to
dry the clothes think about all of the
people in the world using that process
instead in the same amount of time but
one-third the amount of energy needing
to be used to dry the clothes wow that
would be very powerful so there's all
these different options for building the
more sustainable industrialization yes
so as really your problem is pizanno my
knowledge I am only good at chemistry
and biology but that could be
business problem how to like in the past
100 years
physics provided nuclear energy it helps
us a lot but how we how can we come back
all these kind of business laws to make
our world better that it could be more
challenges as well so you this is almost
a call to action man that if we can use
physics to find quantum mechanics which
then gives us smartphones computers GPS
MRI etc we can use physics to make our
drying machines a third more efficient
which would make our sustainable
economies of the world better I like
that I like that so your Zuma's our call
to action to physics and math and
biology and chemistry and a lot of the
scientists did say identify especially
things like these sustainable
development goals of the United Nations
and find the ways that you can
incremental e make a process can these
computers have even more computational
capacity and even less of the resources
that we need to mine from the planet yes
as questions like that can we grow the
clean meat in the bioreactor instead of
slaughtering the animals yeah yeah yeah
I like I like this this idea this these
ways of perceiving the world that's very
good is very important we also talked
about this one before we started to this
idea that if Alibaba and Amazon are
shipping billions of packages every
single year to people and that number is
only increasing and how can we do
something like make a material or or
even just a shipping strategy that is
maybe doesn't require the packaging
materials or very sustainable
biodegradable packaging materials yeah
this challenge can be solved by two
different directions it can be a smart
shipping so maybe you have some glass
container or maybe metal container ship
the steps and then you collect them to
the recipient again that's one possible
solution and other possible solution is
maybe I can use my past knowledge in
material design to make some cheaper and
biodegradable or recyclable materials
that this is just for shipping its
graphing the lightest and strongest
right now Oh actually I do not know the
answer okay I think graphene and I don't
know where that is with carbon fiber but
because graphene can be you can imagine
like a little graphene box on the drone
and then you open the graphene box take
the object from inside and then close it
and the drone takes the graphene box
back if the dome does not use too much
energy that's possible if the drone uses
nuclear fusion for energy I just I love
that idea I really want that to happen
as soon as possible
it'd be great if Wesley pushed further
into fusion as a source of sustainable
energy I'm not sure where they're at
with that right now but that would be a
really good also part of the
multidisciplinary push here
let's talk about forced regulation so
this subject is very interesting like
how do we advance people to make more
sustainable path to industrialization
fastest and a good question is if a
state or a province or a country or
whatever bans the use of something like
a plastic bag or a plastic straw or
whatever it is does it then force
entrepreneurs and people to innovate and
make a more sustainable path faster or
is the too much governmental control
over the economic market forces
sometimes not so good what do you what
do you think about that it's always a
balance so sometimes if you you close
certain industries then it can affect
the people's life for example the top
price in China has increased from 15 to
25 billion in just one year for
half a kilogram of pork meat pork meat
1/2 million 15 - 25 25 un yeah for a
half a kilogram half a kilogram of pork
meat yeah ok just in one year in one
year Wow because the government shuts
down a lot of small farming places so so
less people erase pigs oh is it because
some environmental pollution one finds
you and other issues like the rising
price of soybean protein please
mhm yeah was it where were those smaller
farms not doing the clean practice for
growing though yes but in the same time
so if yep it's for the health of the
people it's for the health other people
in the same time if you can develop new
technologies new technologies that can
replace this kind of environmentally
friendly processes is win-win for all
different parties involved yeah correct
yeah like could may be an incentive from
the government like a big prize or from
a private institution let's say like the
XPrize foundation or whatever maybe they
could say hey instead of putting a
regulation on plastic bags or plastic
straws or or how we grow raised animals
why don't we make a prize from the
government or from private industry that
says how do you solve the plastic bag
issue how do you solve the plastic straw
issue how do you solve the slaughtering
of animals issue and then give them you
know a million-dollar prize and have a
crowdsourcing of ideas for the solutions
to the plastic straws the plastic bags
the slaughtering of animals and then
fund the best one and keep it building
for five ten years and boom you of the
solution the prize model is very
interesting economic incentive is always
the best incentive
yeah economic incentives towards
sustainable industrialization is that
maybe there can be a sustainable
industrialization prizes awarded more
often I like that idea even for the
cyanide stuff we talk about Europe and
China banned the expensive expansion of
a sign that price so nowadays if a
company wants to make new more cyanide
derived chemicals they have to do it
somewhere maybe in South Southeast Asia
or maybe somewhere else
China in Europe banned the further
development of cyanide plants yes let's
have us also get deeper into circular
economics we've been talking about this
throughout but it's eliminating waste
and the continual use of resources from
the system so what would these
advancements mean for our world as we
see Africa and Asia Latin America all
these other places in the world that are
industrializing so fast that how can
there be sustainable industrialization
processes what is that circular
economics that you envision so we like
in the introduction to chemical engineer
a thought out must be pickling one if
you do not have a parents you accumulate
something in the middle so for example
we in the past 300 years for
industrialization we have accumulated a
lot of plastic micro particles in the
ocean in our drinking water we
accumulate a lot of co2 in the
atmosphere so it generates greenhouse
effect
our Croatia is melting and we see a lot
of dead fishes everywhere so this
certification of our oceans yeah yeah so
this kind of circular economy is very
important for our economy our world and
our future generations otherwise we
don't even have a clean place to put our
feet on in the future so this also kind
of takes us back to that example of when
you're you know when you're pouring this
waste water into the river you have to
realize that the interconnectedness of
everything if we are slowly adding more
and more co2 parts-per-million into the
atmosphere creating a greenhouse effect
melting some of the glaciers not only on
land but also in the water the land
one's causing the sea levels to slowly
rise the oceans being acidified the
coral reefs being bleached these types
of things that are happening are in a
sense it's us needing to awaken to the
interconnectedness of everything we
can't just do one thing and expect it to
be in a vacuum it immediately starts
affecting and butterfly effects happen
for the rest of nature and so to us it's
ass wake up call hey humans remember
everything's connected you can't just do
one thing the earth will show you a
wake-up call like the parts per million
co2 rising and these are wake-up calls
for humans
and for us as a scientist we need to
tell develop new technologies that can
meet this kind of newness yeah in more
labs to pop up where young people are
pressing the frontiers of developing
those new technologies and having those
be well-funded
like Wesley having a both private public
fundings vehicle is very useful to
building a world-class Research Center
and I think having that strategy more
prevalent around our world with
institutions being funded like that for
scientific research for building these
tools for these sustainable development
goals and all these types of things are
crucial are crucial like you mentioned
artificial intelligence and big data
being applied so you can run bio
simulations so you can most quickly find
the alternatives to cyanide and roundup
fastest yes and if we don't have those
computational resources it's gonna take
us longer and so how do we fund for
those computational resources and most
effectively so so important let's do a
couple of the questions that we like
asking on our way out so how can we
inspire more people around our world to
work together Oh open the open and use
change ideas yes yes short and sweet
like that
there's an unhealthy change in around
the world right now so with many
countries become more closed
more open and more sharing of the ideas
in collaborative ways and especially on
those great challenges facing every
person on earth yes
so the the butterfly in Amazon can can
cause hurricane in the Met in the
Minnesota may be a hurricane it no no my
aria yeah tornado we do tornado down
yeah yeah yeah so in a sense it would be
lat
all of these advancements that we're
making towards the sustainable
development goals could be open notebook
science so it could be that if you make
a significant advancement you can make
it open notebook for non-commercial use
so people from all different countries
in the world their scientific
researchers could take and like use your
genetically engineered East to continue
that the couldn't be one possibility
yeah stuff like that yeah yeah
what about what do you think is a skill
that young people should know as we go
into the exponential technology age you
need to have some basic chain in
chemistry biology and union for sure
especially in my research direction and
I think in this modern age you do not
need to remember so many things you
always have a computer that they can you
have you can use Google Google can do
your everything by do yep I do
oh so you search you can find a
knowledge in this modern age the most
important thing is how can you combine
all different knowledge to come up with
new solutions new devices new thoughts
that a computer cannot do that anyone
else Canada - it's called personality
you should be your own and your own may
be able to change the world nothing else
ah that answer landed so well with me
yes how can you find the novel pieces of
knowledge combine them into something
that a computer or that other humans
can't do that only you can do what is
your unique gift that you can bring the
world yes that's something Chinese
education system does not put too much
focus on in the past our vast Lake
University can be a new model and I've
been to United States for education for
my PhD for pasta and then for my
starting career and this kind of
personality changing is big for me I
think I learned how to be my own how to
have my own solution
[Music]
in a sense it's like the US has SAT AC T
China has gal cow and we have these
funnels of young people that we think is
most optimal and it's good in some ways
but what about the social skills what
about the emotional intelligence and the
sustainable development goals and
project-based learning and finding your
unique and gifts and finding those
pieces of knowledge and combining them
in ways other people can't and computers
can't being an individual but also being
a node in the collective and knowing how
to do those things effectively otherwise
you will be a machine and then you are
not a data value but in a society yeah
the audio still value but is not optimal
yeah more replaceable
maybe yeah and if you want to be
irreplaceable in the world yes yeah yeah
I like that what would you say is the
meaning of life of this big human
experiment what's the point of it
laughs help and fulfill
what do you think is the role of love
from my only spirit from my own
experience we need to love the planet
planet just like we love our family I
love that cold we need to love our
planet like we love our family it also
brings lots of warmth about that one
and then what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
Nietzsche
nature nature even I to science I still
think the science to deserve nature yes
we all come from nature we all breathe
the air drink the water eat the food and
when we lose a connection to that source
of sustainability for us what sustains
us we have many problems that evolve in
the world so the more we can realize our
including our interconnectedness with
these little guys the more we can live
harmoniously peacefully sustainably yeah
captain thanks so much for coming on the
show this has been a huge pleasure thank
you Thank You Alan thank you thank you
an incredible work you've been doing
here over your years and we look forward
to the advancements of your lab in the
future thank you for your great work
thank you thank you thank you everyone
for tuning in we greatly appreciate it
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below in the episode let us
know what you're thinking have our
conversations with your friends families
co-workers people online about
sustainable industrialization about
circular economics about all the other
topics we talked about in the show about
a more sustainable industrialization
path for Asia for Africa for Latin
America for all these developing
countries around the world for greener
chemical production processes of things
like cyanide of roundup of how to
leverage biological tools like genetic
engineering of yeast and Ecoline feeding
them sugar all these really cool and
interesting things about how you can dry
clothes more effectively launching
physics to help with the sustainable
challenges making more sustainable
polymers making more sustainable
delivering of packaged
about how we can figure out how to best
incentivize the sustainable
industrialized paths check out the links
in the BIOS captions work you can find
the link to its Westlake profile as well
as more links in the bio below support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
organizations around the world that you
believe in supports simulation our links
are below you can find us on paypal
paypal patreon cryptocurrency and design
cool merchants get paid and also go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world do we love me very
much thank you for tuning in and we will
see you soon peace good job good job
good job
[Music]